you're not happy being single Don't
force yourself to pretend that you're
happy that you're
single it's okay to grieve that I miss
somebody yeah and you miss just knowing
that somebody's in the house in case
there's a sound you miss sex you miss
sharing a meal with somebody you miss
silliness you probably even miss the
conflict a little bit just miss
engagement right yeah I wouldn't pretend
that you're not feeling that that's
going to make you insane right or like
to to give you a picture if you take
that feeling and you don't want to feel
it like you press it down you shove it
down or you compress it another word for
that is to depress it